mommy's gonna fashion inside foot
in then ba Center then get ready so you
have to run sometimes you have to take
lots of steps just keep connected you
understand hey hey hey it's not whatever
you're used to
now your shoulders you have to fight you
with your inner deltoid so
going open to much enjoyed your man come
back Center spine elongates then closes
contraction down but they long gates up
finger is extension
down down do you understand that there's
an armed rude that had the kinda innate
organization that doesn't let you
isolate the deltoid okay that's what
you're trying to find but if you keep
doing if you open too much you're gonna
have isolate the Internet's later okay
and same thing if you put your arm like
that if you let it get behind you
so if this dish stays pretty much where
it is is you open like that you should
have inserted come back around
don't throw in your arm you're gonna
okay art is nothing there aren't is
nothing it's all it's all in there you
already know this from me to me not ever
I don't push not push push that's a
clash so I changing her geometry
I'm kidding on the other side of her
head okay I'm over here over here
and I move my face and then I just drop
the way but that's the geometry of the
take down the geometry to take that is
not this
so I'm hittin position
then there's the opening and I'm going
to step in right and then I'll go over
my way that's what I'm doing was eating
a wool so if you look if you look I'm
not here I'm not shoving her down
backward oh then I move into that
opening no this is more reason why our
mats
keep turning even if it turns if it
turns this way you're going to push on
him you have to keep turning the other
way so you should throw like this
some of you start out like you're going
to do it and then you go like that
this way two hands
and watch your back foot hey don't let
your back good brother like that so you
come here yeah I have X amount of
penetration right and I move in this
back foot of the circle I started to get
disjointed you see that money
penetration angle that way but I'm
actually operating this way so make sure
you don't runner yourself and there's no
need in this technique to even pick up
that other foot you're shifting your
weight so that foot has to be stable
boom don't let this foot blood down
just boom and then you're shifting your
weight that back foot driving you into
the technique
have any anyone think that I bring my
arm like that he's gonna stop me okay
arm has to stay in front
so I'm gonna now I accentuate something
good okay
I'm not just doing a letting go why you
guys are so with my Senate contracts
you're bringing them into you okay so
when you go back go to Memphis like that
first part in the same way that we were
doing the street round in the same way
that we were doing that or you picked
them up right there doing the same thing
now with iheanyi it's going down so it
should be able to so you know when you
are going back I'm not pulling him just
with the spiral
I'm going to start pushing this down you
see
elbow and anger as long as possible
which way is the energy going all right
now movie now this is down down on what
okay so walk towards me okay it's still
a hundred yes and now which way is the
energy going okay so which way should
you walk good it is it only going back
alright so back in one ok so let's do
that so follow the energy it went in Fox
that then back down and not back in that
what you want with the motifs when the
boat is moving the dolphin okay so here
we go
yeah that's it so safety here let pull
you in it pulls you in pop that funny
monster grip and then let push you up
walk it fully there you go and walk out
now he's gonna punish us
punch me
and if I have the right groove that
doesn't isolate the deltoid move you're
going to get this parry on the elbow you
don't have to move back as much right so
if you look at my footwork we'll do this
next time I'm out and I'm entering okay
triangle step this hand is doing the
parry boom but it's not just my arm my
spinner has to drop otherwise their arm
is just there you don't get my mic check
so the first move here boom is that
crunch okay it's going down down expand
up and under you might not come here and
do that same with Cammy on the static
version you understand alright dive
under so you see how you look what we're
making contact I'm going on do the right
see where I'm touching you
okay I'm on top outside yeah and that's
push it all down got it okay don't be on
the outside like that very quick it's
just trying to like structurally its
we're utilizing the technique okay but
if you look at my hands positioning
right look my hand dropped right if I
did that on the punch I'm going to get
that but if you look here I'm trying to
keep that elbow so also my footwork was
more fading right we go to the strike
the footwork is lured forward so not
everything is exactly the same but
structurally it is okay
timing is obviously different right
between a ballistic and
obviously different so but in principle
the my is the same the space-time
harmony remains the same got it okay so
we had we have this correction right
don't push on the chest to go around it
well that's time to the same thing if
you hit you feel that Kitty right
you've hit and now you stepped in you
did the same the same
don't try and lower your heart leave
your leave here on where is and let them
change their geometry to do this right
okay then they're not hand over this
she's changing her geometry you got it
so on the other one I kind of made her
head go backwards well this way I'm lady
her feet go forward see and they
accomplished the same thing don't clash
with the head got it
okay so some of you are are terminate on
the punch and you're on BAM like that
alright baby stop IT so you'll feel it
boom I don't feel anything
this way to her violence is broken